uh many of you have emailed me and said
david herschel walker has finally agreed
to a debate against raphael warnock and
i looked at the video and i have to tell
you i don't think rafael warnock is
going to debate herschel walker i don't
really think herschel walker has agreed
to anything when you listen closely to
the video it seems as though he is
putting in place all sorts of conditions
and obstacles but let me back up before
we look at the video
what the hell am i talking about
herschel walker won his republican
primary race in georgia for the senate
now walker will face incumbent
democratic senator raphael warnock one
of the real question marks has been
since herschel walker cannot speak
how could he possibly debate during the
republican primary herschel walker did
not debate and he easily sailed to
victory basically riding on
the wave of uh celebrity
and to some degree probably trump's
endorsement in georgia so
now the question is again coming up is
herschel walker going to debate raphael
warnock and as i've told you before
herschel walker we don't know if it's
some combination of
cte from playing football chronic
traumatic encephalopathy
um
mental illness
uh
whatever we don't know what he really
cannot express himself he can't explain
his positions on issues he often is
completely unable to use words to
assemble meaning and communicate it in
the english language you just can't
speak and there's been a real question
as to how is how is this guy possibly
going to debate the headlines a couple
of days ago were
walker has agreed to a debate he's going
to debate rafael warnock
let's look at two videos
i don't think he's going to debate
rafael warnock here is walker on the
sean hannity fox news propaganda program
listen to what he says will you debate
rafael warnock
well i'm going to open this up on your
show
right now i have accepted a debate in
savannah georgia in his backyard that we
can debate october the 14th
in front of a crowd that it'll be his
people because we're in his backyard and
i it this debate is going to be about
the people it's not about some political
party it's not about the press but the
people need to see the differences
between senator warnock and herschel
walker and what i mean by that they're
going to see that as you just said
georgia don't want high gas prices well
he voted against the pipeline georgia
want to protect our men and women in
blue well he called them names he called
them thugs georgia don't want men and
women's sports where he voted to put men
in women's sports where it is time that
people see the difference so in october
the 14th i want senator warnock to be
ready because i've accepted a debate
then now he can quit talking and show
the people that he's going to stand
behind his words and show up for the
debate okay
so october 14th we don't actually know
that that's a date that's been proposed
or agreed to with raphael warnock
with a crowd
i mean okay so so that's another
condition
it will be a debate about the people not
about a party or the media so does that
mean that raphael warnock and
herschel walker
can't have a moderator what exactly is
it that herschel walker is saying it's
all kind of weird and it feels pretty
soft and squishy so then herschel walker
did another video
this was very clearly by the way this
was very clearly read off of some kind
of teleprompter and this was the best
take that they got and again it's not
really sounding to me like herschel
walker is actually going to debate
anybody listen to this i don't wanna
i'm ready to debate
in fact i just accepted a debate in your
backyard so it's the same talking point
i accepted a debate in your backyard
okay but has one been arranged what does
that mean you've accepted it
where you got home field advantage
and it's going to be broadcast statewide
i'm not a politician
i don't look like a politician i don't
sound like a politician
and frankly i'm tired a politician okay
so i'm not going to obey the demands of
the elite press and delivery
establishment to stand in an empty room
for a debate so to me i'm hearing
if it's a normal debate where there will
be moderators and like some control of
the crowd
walker won't do it that's what i'm
hearing and quite frankly
it's very difficult to imagine that his
campaign advisers would allow him to
debate i mean i understand why he's not
debating because it would be a disaster
that's supposed to be about the people
you see
i don't answer to the press
and i don't answer raphael why not
i don't answer anyone but god
and the people of georgia so what god
has to moderate i mean it's he he's
giving himself so many outs here so i
accepted a debate
that's about voters i'm leaving the
immediate elite behind
and taking my message right to the
people so it sounds like basically he
wants it to be a rally
i mean do we know that herschel walker
knows what a debate is in the political
space like what they look like so they
can see the difference
between the two of us
october 14th
in savannah senator warnock i hope to
see you there
yeah so that's the best take they were
able to get and i mean listen
i have to tell you
if this guy becomes a senator over
raphael warnock
it would be even
more
destructive in what it means about
what's going on in the united states i
mean
trump can at least speak
this guy doesn't understand a single
issue any and he can't speak and then
you look at someone like raphael warnock
who understands issues can explain his
perspective clearly and decisively and
in a way that connects to the english
language
if voters vote for herschel walker and
make him one of 100 us senators i
already think things are sort of in the
toilet in the united states to some
degree politically but it would be like
a 10 to 15 flusher let's put it that way
if herschel walker is able to win so i
hope he debates i don't believe that
this is him really being committed to a
debate
and i think his advisors would be crazy
to allow him to debate let me know what
you think are we going to see him in an
actual debate with rafael warnock find
me on twitter at deepakman we'll take a
quick break and be right back